welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders and
welcome to today's webinar our YouTube
advertising so today we're gonna talk
about YouTube advertising so thanks
again I'm Rob Sanders and I'm with
simply learned and let's get started and
we're gonna do a little role-playing
here and let's just say you're an
advertiser and you're not sure where you
want to advertise your products you have
a product that you want the entire world
to see
well if you want to advertise your
products and let's just say you have
some really good video of your product
that you want to get out there really
there's no other place to look to than
one place in particular is YouTube hence
the reason why we're doing this webinar
because today we're going to talk about
all things YouTube advertising and for
those that don't know YouTube is owned
by Google and a lot of what you're gonna
do is advertise on YouTube via Google
Ads so today we're gonna talk about
YouTube advertising and we're gonna
focus somewhat on Google Ads
so buckle up and let's get started with
why is advertising on YouTube a good
idea so why is it a good idea well if
you haven't been on YouTube of late you
should check it out youtube.com and just
take a look at the vastness of videos
that are on YouTube now YouTube is a
video platform but if it was a search
engine it'd be the second largest search
engine in the world only behind its
parent company Google so it's a very big
platform with a lot of videos and hence
there's some good search functionality
on YouTube so you can look at it as a
search engine
there's 1.9 billion and growing logged
in visitors on a monthly basis so yeah a
lot of people they go to youtube and
watch videos on a daily basis it has
local versions in more than 91 countries
so if you're an advertiser who spoke
in a specific market or you're in a
different market with a different
language you have 91 different options
to hone in on okay so a little bit more
about YouTube here and why is
advertising on YouTube a good idea well
most YouTube users are on mobile almost
70% almost three-quarters of those that
you use YouTube use it from their mobile
device which is staggering but not so
staggering considering most people in
the world now have mobile phones or
mobile devices and most people use their
mobile devices from multiple reasons and
watching videos is one of those reasons
so mobile advertisements receive viewer
attention 83% of the time so what do we
mean by that well on YouTube we have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
people who are watching those videos so
if a lot of people are engaged and
watching a video on YouTube and you're
advertising on that particular video
well then you're going to get some
attention and so that attention has to
be in the eighty percentile okay so a
lot of people are going to you know pay
somewhat attention to your ad and it's
their secret video ads have proven to be
more effective and engaging creating
greater impact and and that's just not
on YouTube I mean that's that's on
Facebook that's on other platforms like
Twitter Instagram so video is an
engaging way to communicate it's a lot
better than traditional text it's a lot
better than say a display banner because
it's engaging people are gonna watch
what you have to say and if they like it
they're gonna share they're gonna
comment on it they're gonna subscribe
there's a lot of things that people can
do when it comes to video advertising so
video helps expand your digital reach so
basically if you are running those text
ads and display ads well having video
kind of adds some more Arsenal to your
advertising portfolio so to speak so if
you're running just those text size and
sleep banners that's fine that's great
cuz you can reach a lot of people but
having video just adds another piece of
the element and because video is so
engaged
you might find that even for yourself if
you're advertising different types of
ads video display or text you'll find
that you know video does have really
really expansive reach to a particular
audience and the other thing here about
YouTube is YouTube helps to find a
relevant audience for your ads using
advanced targeting so just like anything
else that we've talked about here at
simply learn when it comes to
advertising whether that be Facebook or
Instagram or Google Ads we can really
hone in on our audience here and that's
really important and we'll get to that
later because when you're advertising
you want to make sure your ad is in
front of the right people and if we're
talking about video we're talking about
high engagement if you have your video
in front of a really relevant audience
then chances of that audience engagement
gonna be even greater and then YouTube
and video ads themselves provide it
provides a situation that can be
customized to fulfill your marketing
goals and so what do we mean by that so
basically YouTube allows us some
additional features where we can
customize our ads so meaning if our
marketing goal is to just get our ad in
front of millions of people well that's
not a problem if our marketing goals get
people who you know we want to convert
well we can customize our marketing goal
towards that as well
so just like on Facebook and some of
these other platforms we've talked about
YouTube is no different and so we could
set specific marketing goals for our
video ads some other good pointers to
talk about here with YouTube so with
YouTube just like in Google Ads we can
enable running cost effective campaigns
and what do I mean by cost effective
well meaning we can really watch our
budget we can measure how much it costs
for it 1,000 people to watch our video
we can measure how much it costs for
somebody to click on our video ad we can
measure the cost of when somebody clicks
on our video ad and converts how much is
that costing us so you can really run
cost-effective campaigns even on YouTube
and YouTube helps determine how success
or a danced and
so not only do we have analytics on the
YouTube side of the house but we also
have analytics on Google ads and so we
can really hone in and use both
platforms to really figure out exactly
how our ads are performing and then ads
that have reported a 500 percent growth
in views of the channels other videos so
basically you can see growth in views
just by advertising on YouTube so let's
get in now - what are the types of ads
you can run on YouTube so we discussed
all the benefits of YouTube we can go on
for another two or three hours because
there are plenty of benefits but I think
you get the point of you know YouTube be
in a place where you can grow measure
and reach a custom audience so you're
already sold on YouTube now let's talk
about those types of ads you want to run
on YouTube so depending on what goal you
want to achieve with your ads there are
different types of ad formats available
on YouTube so our first set of ads
evolved around building brand awareness
and ad recalls so if you're in the
business promoting your product or your
brand or your service then these are the
type of ads you want to run on YouTube
building brand awareness and ad recalls
because what it does is it's really
going to get your ad out there in front
of thousands and millions of people lots
of eyeballs lots of impressions
impressions are the number of times your
ad versine so ad centered around brand
awareness are really ads that are going
to put you out there in front of a large
number of people with the goal of
potentially attracting new customers and
ensuring your brand is on top of their
mind so top of funnel brand awareness is
always introducing the brand getting
people familiar with the brand and
getting them to your website so that you
can introduce them to your brand and
service and product so that's the whole
idea behind the ads we're gonna
introduce behind the goal building brand
awareness and ad recalls so let's take a
look at what those are so we can build
brand
and ad recalls so we call these these
types of ads TrueView for reach okay so
we say TrueView meaning our ads going to
pair in front of a video and we want to
make sure that that ads in front of a
lot of people so skippable ads that will
enable your brand to reach as many
people and your target audience as
possible at the most efficient price so
the whole idea is for trying to build
brand awareness then we could set it up
on YouTube so there are ad appears
before other videos and that's going to
ensure that our ad is going to show up
in a lot of places based on the audience
we target and if we can get our ad in
front of a lot of people a lot of
targeted people and an efficient price
then how can you say no to that so these
ads are skippable have an open video
length and their bidding is based on
cost per 1,000 impressions so cost per
1,000 impressions CPM means that you're
paying YouTube for every 1,000 people
that looked at your ad okay so that's
what costs per 1,000 impressions or CPM
means that you're paying YouTube not
when somebody clicks on your ad but one
1000 impressions occur and oppression is
when somebody looks at your ad and so
that's where you're going to be paying
YouTube you're gonna be paying it for
1000 views or impressions basically okay
so the ads are skippable but they have
an open video length and it's based on
eyeballs so that's the whole goal there
when it comes to brand awareness you
want to go with a CPM model that ensures
you're getting your ads in front of lots
of people to accumulate impressions and
paid by impressions so this is what the
ad looks like and now we're going to
talk about the type to add that you can
run on YouTube and we call these bumper
ads so they're non skippable ads with
which you can share your brand's message
in six seconds to drive reach and impact
so we've all seen these videos before
and I'm going to share an example with
you here when you're on YouTube you
really can't get to that video that
you really want to watch until you watch
a few seconds of that video ad and so
that's what these bumper ads are they
allow you to really make sure that your
ad is in front of that target audience
still you'd still pay by impressions but
you know that your ads going to run for
a few seconds and the idea behind that
is really you want to get your message
out there and it really does help to
drive reach and impact and so let's take
an example on YouTube of what a bumper
ad looks like so here's an example of a
bumper ad on YouTube and it's only six
seconds but this example it's pretty
popular on YouTube it's been viewed a
lot and we're just going to take a quick
look at this video here this video has
six seconds but the whole point is to
really look at the ads purpose and so we
get playing so that was it that was the
ad six seconds long it appears in in
front of other videos as an
advertisement and the whole point of
these bumper ads is really you have to
get your message out there quickly
because the video is going to start and
you want to really make sure that your
message is being delivered and you want
to keep in this case maybe keep users
guessing as to what it is and so this is
why it's a highly effective ad you know
you got a diver jumping off a diving
board into a pool that is basically
drying up over a period of time and so
for curiosity the old saying is
curiosity kills the cat a lot of people
are probably going to click on that ad
to figure out what is the subject what
are we all talking about here and really
the point of the the video was to bring
awareness about global warming but
that's it that's a six second bumper out
example and you really if you're going
to run bumper ads you want to make sure
that you get your message out there so
it has to have really high impact so
again they're non skippable they have to
be of six seconds and their bidding is
based on again cost going thousand
impressions so it gives you an A
to get that ad out there in front of a
lot of people again your pain on a CPM
model your pain Google for every 1000
impression okay so that's could be 1,000
different eyeballs looking at that ad so
if it's high-impact you know if it's non
skippable then chances are you can get
you know some clicks some some eyeballs
over to your YouTube channel
or to your landing page on your website
so let's take a look at this one from
Alaska Airlines better yeah let's take a
look at this example from Airbnb I found
it to be a little bit more impactful
than the Alaska air one so let's take a
look at this example actually so okay so
high-impact ad great ad by Airbnb really
impact kids playing you have your logo
on the bottom right corner of the video
and you know it gets people excited
about travel so similar to the Alaska
Airlines which we didn't look at this
one is just as good high impactful you
know getting people to you know react
within six seconds isn't exactly a very
easy thing to do so you got to make sure
these videos really resonate within a
time frame that you have so let's take a
look at type three here so we're talking
about reservation of 15 to 20 seconds so
these particular ads can span up to 20
seconds to increase reach and make a
lasting impression so unlike the bumper
ads which were 6 seconds long
these reservation ads tend to run a few
seconds longer up to 20 seconds okay so
they're also non skippable and like I
said it can be up to 20 seconds the
bidding is based on a fixed CPM and when
we omit by fixed CPM well if you're
bidding on a regular CPM model meaning
that you're paying Google for every 1000
impressions that number could be
variable what you pay Google in this
case the fixed CPM is fixed at a certain
rate it could be you know ten dollars
for every 1000 impressions twenty
dollars it really depends on where
you're advertising and who else is
advertising so let's take a look
some examples of a reservation ad on
YouTube up to 15 to 20 seconds long so
here is an example of a 15-second ad you
know also called a TrueView ad so you
can see this ads gonna run for about 15
seconds before the video actually plays
it's non skippable and so let's just
make this a page who can paint the
corners is known as okay so you could
see the ad itself ran a little bit
longer than your traditional or your six
second unskipable version and the 15
second you know allows you to get you
know more the message out there still
high impactful but allows us to get the
message out there with a little bit
longer of a video and that's not
skippable so it's so going to run for
its entirety up to 15 20 seconds before
the video actually starts playing so
let's now turn our attention to the
fourth type of ad you can run on YouTube
and that four type is an out stream
video ad and so these ads are going to
reach users wherever their watch and
regardless of this site or application
it's the whole point of the out stream
we want to be able to get our ads out
there regardless of the site or
application okay so these ads are also
non skippable and they could be 15 to 20
seconds long and their bidding is based
on viewable cost per 1,000 impressions
and so what do we mean by viewable cost
per 1,000 impressions what we mean by
viewable cost per 1,000 impressions is
basically if you're paying for ad
impressions measured as viewable you you
can use this model and basically what
that means that
is counted as viewable when 50% of your
ad shows on screen for one second or
longer or plays continuously for two
seconds or longer so there's some
criteria about the viewable but you're
definitely paying for impressions you're
just paying and when those impressions
showcase the ad 50% or longer or for one
second or longer for you no other type
of video ads or it plays continuously
for two seconds or longer for video ads
so the play is in short if it plays for
longer than two seconds then you're
going to pay for that impression and so
that's going to count as an impression
and that's viewable for one thousand
impressions so if you get your basically
your ad to show for two seconds or
longer then then that's going to count
as an impression so for example with the
viewable CPM for example if you bid on
1000 viewable impressions and you pay
for impressions that are measured as
viewable and a discounted as viewable
again when 50% of your ad shows on the
screen for one second or longer for
display ads and two seconds or longer
for video ads so so that's basically
what it's about so really the key number
here with viewable CPM is two seconds or
longer that's the difference between
regular 1,000 impressions CPM and
viewable 1000 impressions v CPM so let's
talk about the next type of ad format
you can run on YouTube and the next one
is masthead and so mass that is unique
in that basically they only run for 24
hours okay so and they run on youtubes
homepage so you can imagine the amount
of reach that you can have by
advertising on youtubes homepage so
they're highly visible okay they can run
on multiple devices desktop app mobile
and basically these ads sit at the top
of YouTube's homepage so their fixed
cost per day pricing involved and so the
best thing to do is to contact YouTube
if you're interested in advertising on
youtubes homepage
that's the masthead advertising and
basically these ads are non skippable
they have an open length and again their
bidding is based on fixed price per day
so here's an example of what the
masthead looks like on the homepage so
you can see here this is that GMC ad
okay you can see that they have video
supported with a banner and you know
call-to-action out there and so what
YouTube is actually experimenting with
are you know different ways for
advertisers to buy masthead ads okay so
it's you know these ads are very
prominent so it's it's basically YouTube
is now offering the option to buy
masthead ads on a cost per 1,000
impressions a ciseaux they're playing
around with that cost format so just
keep in mind that this is a recent
change by YouTube so traditionally its
cost per day but now they're actually
offering the option for advertisers to
buy a masthead ad' on a CPM basis so
just keep that in mind you do you do
have the option here so at the end of
the day if you're interested in mass has
ads and having your ads show up on
youtubes homepage for 24 hours I would
still contact Google and I ask them
about hey I want to pay cost per 1,000
impressions so YouTube is actually
offering up that option on pricey model
so the second set of ads we're gonna
focus in on are centered around this
strategy of growth consideration and
interest and the whole idea behind
growth consideration and interest is
really we want to get our ads in front
of people who could be potential
customers but we want to influence them
okay we want to influence them at a
point in time when may when we think
they're gonna be most receptive to our
message so that really means getting our
ad out in front of the right audience at
the right time because the message we
put out there it's going to be centered
around you know getting them to not only
take notice of our brand potentially
take action so it's moving our audience
a little further down that funnel so
really growth consideration and in
it's all about placing your ad your
message in front of that potential
customer when you think they're going to
be most receptive to the messaging
you're putting out so that's what growth
consideration and interest is so let's
go back and look at let's talk a little
bit more about those TrueView ads so
TrueView ads are one of the most popular
ways of advertising on YouTube so if
you're interested and you know getting
growth getting leads getting conversions
you might want to think about some
TrueView ads because basically these ads
can run before during or after videos on
YouTube or you can run them on video
partner sites and applications again if
you're interested in driving not just
brand awareness but you know clicks to
your site so if you're interested in
driving impact for your brand of
products you might want to focus on the
TrueView in-stream ads again these are
the traditional ads you've probably seen
before on YouTube that run before during
or after a video and these ads are
skippable so you're likely to have seen
the skip ad call-to-action button they
have an open video length and their
bidding is based on cost per view so
you're paying when somebody views you're
at and so what what does that mean cost
per view let's break that down cost per
view bidding is the default way to set
the amount you'll pay for a true view
video ad so what do you actually pan
well your pain when somebody views your
video and but there's a threshold here
so a view is counted on YouTube when
someone watches 30 at least 30 seconds
of your video ad or if it's shorter than
30 seconds and let's just say it's 20
seconds then that's going to be
considered a view
so 30 seconds of the number here you
need to be concerned about when you're
running and cost per view model so if
you have a video that's one minute long
and they watch 30 seconds it's
considered a view and that's what you're
going to pay you're going to pay cost
per view so that's what the cost per
view model is and that's the really the
default model with true
ads whether that be before the video
during the video or after the video it's
its cost per view so let's talk about
the other type of TrueView ad that's the
TrueView discovery and so basically what
treeview discovery is is your ads are
placed and youtube search results next
to related videos or on the YouTube
homepage so you're getting your ad
discovered more or less you know
throughout YouTube and including the
YouTube homepage so here's an example of
what that looks for looks like and so
let's jump over to YouTube and take a
look at that so if I do type in let's
just say surfing I may scroll down and I
may see some ads I may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have ad next to it and so that's when
you know your ad is being discovered on
YouTube and so here in this example we
don't see any ads showing up here so
remember those TrueView discovery ads
are going to have something with the ad
next to them that way you know it's an
advertisement and they're gonna be found
in the search results on youtubes
homepage or any page where you're
actually searching a third set of ad
types enter around driving action and so
the whole point of driving action is
getting that potential customer to
actually take action on the ad the PC so
in the case of videos we're gonna have
some call to action stronger call to
action to get these folks over to the
website to purchase or download or you
know sign up for a newsletter or do
something you want them to do in terms
of your business model so if your
business model is selling a product then
the whole point of driving action on
your ad is getting them to buy your
product we want so the whole point of
driving action is making it easier for
customers to take meaningful actions
that you can measure so the ads we're
gonna introduce are centered around
getting potential customers to take
action okay so that's what driving
action is further down the funnel and
getting folks to react to your ad so
that they can
the action that's aligned with your
business talking about true view ads now
and so again these ads discovery can
show up on search results on youtubes
homepage you have your traditional in
stream true view ads where they show up
before during or after and then here you
have true view for action and so these
true prefer action ads are video ads to
drive any action that's important to
your business so again it goes back to
that marketing strategy so the ads we
looked at on early on or about
impressions so a lot of the cost models
for a lot of the ad types were cost per
1000 impression and notice now that you
know it's it's now cost per view for
true view ads and you want to be on a
different model when your marketing
strategy is more aligned with getting
people to take action that's important
to your business for example shopping or
buying something or getting a quote or
or downloading something so if that's
your marketing goal you want to go with
a true view for action if that's what's
important your business because these
ads are intended to get users to
interact with a clickable button that
leads to your site so that's the whole
idea behind true view for action type
ads okay so these are skippable they
have an open video length and their
bidding is based on cost per acquisition
so CPA different cost models so let's
now talk about what CPA is so the cost
per acquisition model is in this case
since we're trying to drive action we're
going to pay when somebody actually
takes that action so if somebody
actually does shop and they spend $20.00
then basically you're gonna pay for that
acquisition so basically if it's to
download something whatever it cost for
you to get that person over and they
actually download that's what you're
going to pay so cost per acquisition is
really a model based on action so when
somebody actually performs that action
that's when you're actually going to pay
Google so that's what CPA is and that's
what the YouTube true view for action
ads are all about try
Drive action so let's talk about the
universal app campaign for video and so
this is all about driving action as well
so these ads promote your app on YouTube
so where your ads are more likely to be
clicked and your app downloaded so again
targeting an audience and really it's
about you know getting people to look at
your application your mobile app so
that's what these ads are all about
they're about promoting your mobile app
on YouTube okay so these ads are
skippable okay they haven't opened video
length okay meaning you can make them as
long as you want and again their bidding
is cost per acquisition but you also
have some additional models them as well
so we already talked about what cost per
acquisition is because this is a actual
based ad so we want people to do
something like download our app but you
also have another cost model here cost
per install and you only pay when that
person who watches or sees that ad
clicks on it and actually does install
the app okay you also have another model
that you can apply here and that's the
return on adspend
and a return on adspend basically is
you're asking Google hey I want to make
sure that if I'm gonna run this type of
that I'm getting my return on investment
meaning if I spend $100 am i getting a
hundred and one dollars back so that's
the return on adspend
that's a cost per install and a cost per
acquisition so you have three models
here for the universal app campaign
that's some important metric for YouTube
so we thrown all around a lot of
different cost models when we talk about
the different types of advertising you
can do on YouTube and so with that
there's a lot of metrics so let's go
through some of these metrics here you
have views clicks your view rate so you
have all these different types of
metrics and for some of you it could be
confusing so what am I need to look like
look at what do I need to measure so it
really does come down to you know what's
important to your business that's always
first and for
most but here we listed some of the most
common metrics available to you with
YouTube okay so let's go through some of
these and basically a view is just it
shows the number of times people watched
or engaged with your video ad so a view
rate is basically the number of views or
engagement your ad receives and the
number of times your ad is shown
okay so divided by the number of times
your ad was shown into the number of
engagements so if your ad was shown a
hundred times and you had one liked or
one click for example then that would be
one percent so average cost per view is
the average amount you pay whenever you
are watches 30 seconds of your videos so
remember when you're on a cost per view
model remember 30 seconds is the magic
number so if your video is only 25
seconds then remember that's going to be
the view so it's got to be minimum or
maximum 30 seconds if your videos under
30 seconds it's 25 seconds or 20 as an
example then it's still going to count
as a view if it's a minute and somebody
watched at least 30 seconds of it then
that's going to count as a view so just
keep in mind 30 seconds is the magic
number here for the view so if somebody
watches at least 30 seconds of your
video or engages with your video that
would be a cost per view so that's the
average amount you're gonna pay and
watch time is basically it measured the
total amount of time people watched your
video ads shown in seconds okay so it's
the total amount of time so it gives you
an idea of how many minutes total your
video is run so let's focus on clicks so
clicks is a common metric across the
board it shows the number of times
people actually clicked on your video
not to be confused the view to views the
number of times your video was actually
watched a click is something also
measurable and it's when somebody
actually clicked on it so it's an
indicator for how well your ads are
doing with those who see it and so you
know we want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type video ads if we're running those
action at type ads or universal app ads
we're going to want people to take
action
if you're running ads just for
impressions that's one thing so clicks
is an important metric depending on the
type of video ad you're running so click
the rate is a number of clicks you
receive from your ad divided by the
number of times the ad was shown so my
ad was shown a hundred times and I
received one click then that's one
percent click-through rate so let's talk
about engagement an engagement is the
number clicks on interactive elements
such as icons in your video ad ok so
that's what an engagement is here the
number of clicks on interactive elements
and then if we look at engagement rate
then and it clicks on an interactive
element that we receive is gonna be
divided by the number of times the ad
michelle so that's why we have
engagement rate as well so we want
people to engage with our video is there
something that they're doing on the
video if so then what's the rate at
which they're engaging earned views so
that's a number of views who have seen
subsequent videos on your channel or
watch pages after seeing your ads so
watch pages or videos on your channel
and have you've seen those after seeing
your ad then that's gonna be called in
earned views so somebody's seen your ad
and was impacted by what they saw if we
look back at the examples we shown
earlier on with the global warming or
the GMC or the Airbnb ads you know if I
saw those ads and I said man that's
really a cool ad or that's really a good
message I'm gonna go over to that that
watch page or I'm gonna go over to that
channel and see what other videos they
have when you do that that's an urn view
and then if you can get an urn view
you're probably gonna get an urn
subscriber because it's the number of
viewers who subscribe to your channel
after seeing your ad so again going back
to any of the ads that you've ever seen
you've ever gone over to their channel
and then subscribe to the channel that's
an urn subscriber so your video ad is
doing something for you it's in this
case it's getting you a subscriber so
let's talk about how to create a YouTube
ad so this is going to require some
access to Google Ads and we'll go over
that a few minutes here but first
we need to think about setting up a
campaign and setting up a campaign goal
okay what's the goal of our campaign to
get eyeballs you know we want to pay
costs per 1,000 impressions or we want
to run some actionable type ads to get
people over to our website so that
really is step one we need to identify
what the goal of our campaign it then we
need to create the ad so we want to be
able to create a video out here that is
going to show on YouTube and to our
target audience so or whether it be a
bumper ad that's only gonna be six
seconds long we need to be able to
figure out what type of ad we want to
run so here I am in Google Ads if we're
going to run a campaign on YouTube
we need to make sure that we're choosing
a display campaign and so remember the
first step is you know setting up that
campaign setting up that campaign goal
so we're gonna go ahead and select a new
campaign here we're gonna run a new
campaign and so what's the goal of our
campaign so if we're just out to
generate brand awareness and reach
that's certainly fine if it's all about
sales or if it's all about leads then
you know the type of video run is gonna
be a little bit different so we select
brand awareness and reach okay here
we're gonna select the campaign type and
so if we select video basically what
we're doing is we're gonna tell Google
we want to go ahead and set up some
video ads on YouTube and so here you
could see the different types of video
ads we discussed today you know we got
your bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non skippable so the
difference being at if it's non
skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're going to
go ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're gonna click continue and then once
we do that you know we're gonna get
prompted to you know move forward with
selecting our ad so you can see here
after I set up my campaign
now I'm just gonna go through some of
the settings for my ad and I'm gonna
give it a campaign name a budget okay
when it starts or ends the bidding
strategy so again we're gonna focus on
cost per 1,000 impressions and then
here's the network so this is an
important selection here so we're
dealing with YouTube videos so we're
also have the option to select video
partners on the Display Network so that
means that if you want your video to
show on websites that want to host ads
in video format then you can select this
option here notice you also have this
option available if you're running
certain types of ads on YouTube we're
running those bumper ads so bumper ads
aren't available on search results so
I'm gonna stick with the video partners
okay YouTube videos and here we can get
into some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what Google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're gonna have an ad group so
when you create an a campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less of video in every agric we have but
we have to have at least one ad group so
we're gonna go ahead and set up you know
this a group here and here's where it
gets interesting and important because
here is where we could start targeting
our audience so here we got demographics
okay so we can choose gender age
parental status household income okay we
can focus in on audiences if we want to
so we can we can choose a specific
audience that we've set up we can get
some ideas or browse specific audiences
we could also choose a specific
placement so here you have YouTube
videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember
in this example we're going to bump her
out so we're looking at about six
seconds and once we do that then that's
pretty much the campaign but I just want
to stress here that when you're setting
it up ahead of time you want to make
sure you identify what the campaign goal
is and then that's going to align with
the type of video you're gonna run and
then once you choose that type of video
then it just comes down to where you
want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so it's really crucial here
that you go through these steps and
these options very closely so because
you want your video to show in front of
the right audience on the right
placement so let's talk about how you
can optimize your YouTube ads so once
you get your campaign set up once you
select your channel or the type of
videos where you want your ad to be and
you select your target audience and
you're off and running with your video
ad well we're gonna give you some tips
here that you can focus on for
optimizing those ads and so going back
to what I was just saying on the setup
you want to carefully define your
metrics and goals okay so that's step
one so when you're setting up the
campaign remember you have that option
to choose the type of goal for your
campaign that can be brand awareness it
could be a sale it could be a lead so to
me that's a you know a very critical
step one so you want to make sure you
align your goal with your video and then
the second is track low performing ad
placements so if we just ask Google to
place our video ads anywhere they want
then it's up to us then to go through
and choose the ad placements and remove
them okay so let me show you an example
of what that means so fun back in Google
I'm gonna go to my campaign and I'm
gonna select placements and here I could
see placements but then I'm gonna select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it
it and exclude it from the campaign or
advert so that's really the key is you
want to be able to manage your
placements properly and when we say low
performing at placements we mean really
what what's your goal if your goal is to
get sales or leads if your that
placement is not converting sales or
leads then you need to remove or exclude
that placement so it's all done within
the Google ads platform and then you
know you can also use a custom thumbnail
image and your ad as well it's always
helpful in terms of optimization so a
couple of other pointers here to help
you optimize you want to drive people to
perform a particular action with the
appropriate CTA so again depending on
the ad type you know it's a true view at
20 seconds long you want to have a call
to action you want to maybe even have
your domain name at the end of the video
so at least somebody knows where to go
so you always want to have a call to
action with your video ad you want to
use negative targeting specify who gets
to see your ad and who doesn't okay so
that goes back to your settings so you
can pick and choose who your target
audience is you can pick and choose who
you don't want your audience to be is
another setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ads all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive you can always perform a be
testing on your ads so if you have one
ad version you can create another one
just to see what it which one performs
better testing is always a positive okay
so if you're paying too much maybe think
about reducing your bids so if you
remember we set a $10 CPM bit that may
be too much maybe we don't need to pay
$10 so we can always reduce our bids at
the ad group level so reduce bids in
areas where you see lower performance so
in other words you don't want to pay a
lot for poor performance you can also
use remarketing to re-engage with
customers so if somebody views your ads
and doesn't take action you can always
retarget that person to show your ad
another
even another ad format it could be text
ads or display ads but if somebody
looked at your video and they didn't
take the action you preferred them to
take then you can always return at them
with another ad so that's a good way to
optimize so we want to make sure the ad
has content that what viewers would find
relevant okay that really you want to
make sure that your ad is you know is
with the end viewer you don't want to
put out an ad that isn't going to give
somebody you know a good feeling after
they watched it okay so you want to make
sure viewers find the content relevant
so they don't find a relevant the Matt
means your engagement rate and your
engagements probably going to be low so
you want to take a look at those metrics
that we viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impact fall and so with any ad
you run any video ad you're on you
really want to make sure that that
message is conveyed at the very
beginning early as possible otherwise
you know people are gonna be turned off
from non engage and just gonna go ahead
and skip it anyway so you want to make
sure you get the purpose of it right up
front and out of the way okay you can
also include visual and auditory
components in your ad that can make it
more memorable to the viewers okay
meaning music or other cool visuals
okay so again you want to be able to
play around and test different ads and
you want to be able to you measure the
ad performance based on the metrics we
discuss I mean click the rate engagement
rate all of those are indicators whether
the ad is of good quality or not with
the end user and when I say good quality
I mean to be fine and engaging do they
find it interest in there so they're
gonna click and if you don't have good
click-through rates from good
engagements then you definitely want to
try doing something different to the app
like adding those audio components or
other visuals that could be appealing to
the end user so go ahead and and
some of those out with a/b testing
because you have nothing to lose but
higher or lower engagement rates or
lower quick your rates so you want to be
able to improve those metrics improving
those metrics means trying some
different components on different ads so
let's take a look at a case study if you
will and let's focus on Superdry so
they're a good success story on youtube
so SuperDrive leaned on some YouTube
advertising to help lift one of their
products so in September last year 2018
Superdry if you're not familiar with the
brand they're you know centered some
Asian markets European markets and they
focus in on clothing different styles
and sizes and genders from jackets to
jeans to t shirts and so they're global
brand they really wanted to take a
different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so what
they've done is they set up some
campaigns on YouTube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interest and so what they
did was they want to want to take
advantage of all the different ad types
that YouTube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to YouTube and let's just take a look
at this one minute add here 53 second ad
buy super dry this is the jacket the
jacket you're raising the jacket you're
waiting the jacket you're cooling the
jacket your play
and Poland
you'll take five in this turkey take
away free templates
catch your breath not you this in this
jacket just a jacket your Prius
this is the jacket the Jackie that will
get you so that's the video that's super
dry ran you could see that you know it
was had some particular goals there and
so super dry is pretty well known so
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dries
account and these videos actually had
you know four point eight million views
and so cool video ran for fifty three
seconds that a long time not a short
time was able to you know target their
audience a younger crowd you noticed in
the eye they have different jackets both
female and male different gender types
so they were messaging a very broad
audience gender some younger people as
who they were targeting so younger
people tend to slant on YouTube and so
they were able to get some nice views
out of it four point eight million but
the more important thing is because
these videos were to drive action and so
they were able to see a four to one
ratio on return on investment and as a
result these jackets saw a hundred and
thirty eight percent increase in brand
lip I mean the jacket add so it was a
pretty successful campaign see is
well-choreographed good audio good video
just well professionally done and they
probably were able to now get a few more
loyal customers under their belt because
of this ad alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and target them with a cool video
and given that YouTube is vast then you
can really take advantage of a lot of
their ads so what they probably did it
again was there's TrueView in-stream ads
with a cost per view through a skippable
video ad format may they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on YouTube so they took advantage
of all YouTube had offer in terms of who
they were trying to target the length of
the ad and given that their product or
selling a product or promoting a product
they will take advantage of the TrueView
shoppable ad format which basically
lists your products alongside the actual
video app and so this is just a good
case study you Superdry will probably do
this again based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats so
I want to thank you for joining if you
have any comments on your experiences
with YouTube or even this video itself
or the Superdry case study feel free to
comment under this video and if you're
looking for more information please
visit us at simply learn com thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here